[Music]
for example Joe Biden tweeted this he
tweeted anyone who says I don't do
anything important hasn't seen my new
sofa for
there's one Kim jong-un tweeted this
yo dogs check out my hot new series of
looking through binoculars photos chris
christie tweeted this one did you know
some airlines make you buy two seats
when you're only hungry for one donald
trump tweeted this i only got a hundred
and forty characters on twitter better
use them wisely Trump Trump Trump Trump
Trump Trump Trump Trump Trump Trump
Trump Trump Nicolas Cage tweeted this I
know my last few movies haven't been all
that great but wait till you see my next
one turd demon for the curtain a
[Applause]
turdy I want to see turd demon for I
want to see one through three first I
don't want to not know what's going on
turning yeah you can't come in late my
turd name you've got to know we got all
the plot the trilogy the head of the NRA
Wayne LaPierre tweeted this man Game of
Thrones sure would be better if they
used guns so would Project Runway Andy
Richter tweeted this since Conan doesn't
follow me on Twitter he'll never know
that I peed in his sock drawer Chris
Brown tweeted this sometimes a
relationship can feel like work you
punch in you punch out here oh my
Harrison Ford tweeted this very excited
to start filming on my new Star Wars
check I mean movie Wilford Brimley
tweeted this in my day we didn't need no
damn Twitter we just ate oatmeal and
chop trees down hey get your hands off
me orderlies I ain't going back on that
tariff you dick salt back
that's pretty good yeah texting well a
polar bear tweeted this look how cute I
am get closer you tasty bastards
Nicolas Cage tweeted this great news my
next film is being released straight to
yard sales
the turd name
and finally Larry King tweeted Twitter
hell I remember when Earth's only had a
hundred and forty characters
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]